pour la deuxième fois cette année la SAC
ose ses prix
normal avec les temps qui courent 1458
produits subiront une hausse de 2,4 %,
ce qui représente 69 centres en moyenne
539 produits seront moins chers
d'environ 1,3% soit 28 centres et les
prix de 1389 produits resteront stables
les coups de transport et les problèmes
d'approvisionnement en sont
principalement la cause les coûts de
production des de nos fournisseurs qui
sont plus grands donc pénurie de main
d'oeuvre notamment approvisionnement
aussi de matières sèche donc des
bouchons les bouteilles tout est tout
est plus compliqué à obtenir la baisse
des prix sur certains produits
s'expliquent par la fluctuation de la
monnaie eu la dépréciation de l'euro
donc le rôle baissé progressivement dans
les derniers mois donc ça se reflète
dans le prix et ce qui explique la
grande majorité des baisses
en 2022 acheter une bouteille de vin ou
de spiritueux coûte en moyenne 3,6% plus
cher qu'en 2021 et 9 fois sur dix la
hausse s'applique sur un des articles
les plus populaires la SAC performe
relativement bien depuis quelques années
en fait l'ensemble des des commissions
de liqueur à travers le pays fonctionne
bien les rendements sont excellents
d'appliquer une hausse quelques semaines
avant les fêtes c'est c'est un peu
opportuniste à mon avis en 2021 les
revenus versés au gouvernement du Québec
étaient de 1,2 milliards de dollars en
Ontario la lcibio a remis 2,4 milliards
pour la même période
les prix simplement pour augmenter les
dividendes la hausse vertigineuse du
coup de la vie force les consommateurs à
changer leurs habitudes et je regarde
beaucoup plus les prix qu'avant vraiment
là j'essaie de trouver
des rabais des des vins qui sont quand
même bon puis moins cher et mettre un
peu d'eau dans son vin ici Marie-Josée
Paquette como Radio-Canada Montréal